wrong with people yeah what kind of
advice did you expect me to give you
it's the honest question you should be
asking us
well going guys we are back again
for another sng special you know the
vibes you know the vibes
as per hit that like button drop a quick
uh comment drop a nice review
jump on the patreon real quick run me my
p
just quickly just quickly it's a quick
sign up process
run me my p real quick just the first
tier one
because yeah fam ding bang bang done
because
i think we've told you already we're
looking to quit our jobs
december this year yeah 2021 december
end of december we're quitting
and you're either with us or against us
you're either with us or you're against
us that's hilarious that's all i know
so yeah yeah i mean you know who's with
us sam i don't know come december we
could see
you in my dms like yeah yeah i love the
part is so funny i will scroll for my
patrons and see who's there
i'll block you out if you went in there
if december comes and i didn't get to
quit and you're up in my dms the next
day talking about you love this and that
and i scroll through my patrons and your
name and about blocked
blocked you're against me you don't want
us to wait
you'll see the reply you won't know what
to think because you'll see the pride
from me and they'll be like
safe you're against me my message you're
part of the problem
i remember that what's going on there'll
be a lot
of responses you're part of the problem
that's hilarious it is what it is but um
now bro enjoy the content on there um
it's good stuff
two episodes every month and uh yeah
ma'am without further ado
fun fact of the day guys um so
this is this one's a random one actually
the g sp yeah i couldn't get my words
out the g spot
was almost called the whipple tickle
after it was discovered by dr beverly
whipple
so hence the whipple tickle but dr
whipple decided to name it
after dr ernst graffenberg the first
person to propose the existence of the
uniquely sensitive region
hence the g-spot
cool man yeah what is the g-spot really
about
it's in terms of what in terms of i know
what it is
oh so you know i know where it is right
but like what is it actually about like
not in terms of like
biologically or anything like that but
it's like um how do i explain it
maybe a gay dog needs to hit me up
because obviously
i know what women say about it and
obviously guys have one
up the pooper so it's about
the sensitive area a sensitive area but
like
um so for example i've had loads of
conversations with women in the past and
and it always comes down to this anal
chat in it
just like uh what would you do like if a
girl wants to put a finger up yours or
something like that
and i'm always like obviously it's a
night and then their rebuttal is always
um
the g-spot is up there i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm
good i'm actually fine like i've been
doing all right so far
i don't feel like i'm missing out yeah i
mean but then i don't know maybe a
gaydon might hit me up and just be like
bro fam you're missing out
my eyes are widened my eyes are wide or
i swear swear tell me more
exactly that's what that's when that's
that's the question i'm asking what's
it all about okay he might hit me up
like fam you are missing out
my eyes roll back tell people tell me
more
because apparently it makes you nah i've
heard it makes you not
and i've been nutting just fine midnight
that's what i do
ah but yeah it could be a it could be a
vibe i don't know i'm not even willing
to experiment just someone tell me
yeah let me know and i'll let you know
from there whether i'm going next
because i'm
i'm fine as it is yeah it's similar to
like um
how do i how do i explain it what's
something that people preach but i'm
like i'm fine
um i don't know maybe like
something to do with the ocean i hate
the ocean maybe like
um like scuba diving is one thing for me
people are it's unbelievable like it's
life-changing you have to try it
and i'm like i'm actually good like i'm
fine
but maybe it would take someone who's on
my level yeah who hate sharks and hate
this
to hit me up and i know they're on my
level and be like james
trump you don't know what you're missing
it's the most unbelievable experience
that's what i need yeah i need a donnie
who is it maybe even a gay i wouldn't
even be
the right example i need a guy who's
just been out here busting nuts in pum
is not interested in that i need you
that's what i need it's what i'm getting
at
i need you to tell me well
james you need to get your someone to
stick your finger i was shivering
that's what i need to hear james i was
against it but now i'm all for it
just nothing ah i'll shake it oh my god
i said i need you his wish on that level
where i can be like bet
i i agree i i understand like i believe
you
i truly well and truly believe you
that's what i need i couldn't go first
i couldn't go faster you'd have to go
first i'm not going first
i'll be scared i'm ticklish
i'm ticklish so i could it's one of the
things i couldn't know it's going to
happen that day
oh yeah rags it couldn't have been like
tonight is
we're going to test this g-spot thing
tonight no i'll be scared
it's just done you've just certified i'm
not coming over yeah it has to be a
sneak attack but not a surprise like
you know what i mean it has to be like a
smooth it has to be she has to be
all up
before i know it it's in there we're
there we're there and there's not much i
can do
because there's been times where it's
close to have not necessarily
a finger up there but like the tongue
area
we're all yeah where she's she's been
all up in there so
bubbles galore and she's just going
lower and lower and i'm thinking this
could be the day
someone licks my ass because it's never
happened to me before and it's not
something i would
i've obviously said that i would never
want it i think i've said it on here
before
but it's also something that if they ask
me
can i do it i'd say no but if it
happened to happen in the right moment
you just have to accept it
do you know what i mean and there are
times where it's almost happening
and i'm thinking [ __ ] this could happen
i don't i also know
like what she's doing at the moment i
don't want to stop watching yeah yeah
yeah i'm not
everyone's still having a good time yeah
i never want to try and kill the moon
yeah yeah
yeah so if it happens now it happens if
it happens now it happens but
thank the lord yeah i like to feel like
i'll take the lord i need to
i need to feel like ah it's happening as
naturally for me as it is for her yeah
she didn't have a plan to get here but
we're just ending up here and we're
rolling the roller coaster and what
happens happens that's what needs to
happen for me
because yeah there's no way i can feel
if i feel for a second that this is
orchestrated yeah i'll kick you off
i'll kick you off bruv i'll panic rags
and she has to be like we said in the
previous episode she has to be um i
think we'll have the previous episode
before
she has to be um dominant but
confidently dominant about it as well
she has to know what she's doing
it couldn't be like a she couldn't be as
para as i am yeah
if i feel like a little and then she
peeps to see my reaction get off me
get off me do you know what i mean yeah
yeah because we're not we're not in the
same place
the same way i know i'm gonna eat you
out you need to be for it you need to
think that
i'm even if i've told you i'm not about
it yeah you need to assume i'm about
anything any and everything and this is
just
the next logical step yeah like you said
but she's just all about
everything there's bubbles everywhere
yeah and i'm dripping wet
and then this just makes sense and then
that's the way you just go you
you're not even thinking about it i'm
not thinking about it that's just where
you go trust me i'm thinking about it
if i get like you know the the first
line of your ass cheek
yeah if if i'm feeling anything there
i'm already terrified
i'm concerned i'm dripping sheets i'm
i'm i'm grouping i'm staring and i'm
breathing
i'm mouth breathing uh my breath will be
shaking
and everything you got this bro the ones
i hate the most obvious this is a lot of
sex child like the first five minutes it
is um when she's like when she's giving
your hair done like she's like no she's
not giving you hair she's like playing
with the balls but she's stroking you at
the same time
but she can she can see you do you know
what i mean yeah she can see you so
she's there she's looking at you
looking at me kind of thing but i
sometimes think is she looking at me
because
she's about to go down she wants to know
if i'm prepared
or she's just giving me eye contact
like two minutes or whatever petrify me
yeah yeah cause i don't know what she's
gonna do next and i'm not gonna be like
come on come on come on come on
are they pet bro bro it's a lot of
stress bro that's why
maybe i should just get over what i know
this is not what i need bro what i
signed up for oh
i should just get over with
it is because i just like i would not
happily but
i've obviously eaten ass before and i
would happily do it again to
certain females i won't do to any female
you know i mean but it's one of them
ones where
i feel like in that context that guy to
a girl is just
calm you know what i mean it's just calm
because i mean
i'm there anyway i'm there i'm here for
all of it i might as well do you know
what i mean so
when it's when the roles are reversed my
[ __ ] has never been licked in my
lifetime in the 30 years i've been
living
bro so the first time it happens i'm a
bit nervous yeah
i mean i thought it made me feel
comfortable exactly and man for me as
well like
ladies you guys get that brazilian and
wax you man i clean you man
you don't know what you're getting
yourself into big money i don't even
know what's there i can't see it
you know what i mean i don't even know
what's there no one's ever seen it
no one's ever seen are you man sure you
want this
bro neither of us know what you're
getting yourself into it's so
it's it's funny yeah boy ah it's long
but uh yeah
yeah we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll
see that's funny
yeah we'll see if i get a dm about this
uh g-spot thing
just pre-eyes i'll get those those eyes
like james james
trust me take my word
take my word ah i don't know
that's the thing i couldn't take i
couldn't i could take anyone's word i
couldn't take it i need
a close personal friend to tell me bro
trust me it's the wave
oh god okay we'll see
damn i can i can imagine obviously
because i don't know but i can imagine
like
a chick just sticking her finger up and
just tossing me off
and the nut is outrageous
do you know what i mean the nut is just
outrageous like
my nut will take your eye out kind of
thing i can imagine
i actually can't imagine
i can't imagine i can't imagine bro the
thought of anything inside me
i'm not too scared to say i can't
imagine bro i can't imagine
i can't imagine but uh within the same
breath
when i'm like um if i'm eating pum and
you know when you're
it's it's an awkward angle but like you
know when you're you're stink's in and
eating at the same time yes
while she's laying on her back well
she's she's laying on the back yeah
you're doing mad
tongue action and then you're just like
fingering away yeah
when they not i'm thinking oh and i bet
that was just
fantastic great yeah i bet you had a
wonderful time yeah so i can imagine
yeah
if there's mouth involved there's
fingers involved there's a hand involved
everything's all like i can imagine with
you not it but it's fireworks
mind-blowing
i'm i'm sure it's great but bro that's
that's a line i i don't know if i'm
ready to grasp
because i'm still gonna nut today i mean
so far my nuts
aren't underwhelming yeah do i mean i'm
still good enough
i'm not searching the next best nut
that's to say that
but uh jesus christ mentioned i'm not
ashamed to say i'm willing to find out
i can imagine i can imagine i'm sure
it's
[ __ ] great but uh it's a scary
concept because imagine if imagine if
donnie imagine if that sixth man were
like bro
big man thingy is actually the lick and
then you went you know what [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it i'm a girl man i'm gonna do it
and then a thing just hollers you
you'll do anything and then she goes for
it and it turns out to be
every bit as dreadful as you thought it
might be oh my god and you hit these man
up like bro you told me it was sick
because
i was joking film i was joking as if you
actually did it
that's terrifying that's also
emasculating
it's everything yeah i feel i feel so
small
yeah i feel so small oh
this thing as well imagine this not even
imagine this but obviously
when you said about the you're scared
she's going to go for it and stuff like
that
um obviously you have all this fear
this innate fear that we have about it
about that region
and that's still under the premise that
all we've heard is good things
um through if one person hollers me and
says i've had it done and it was
torture i am certified now now that
anxiety's through the room
i'm never going to do it never in a
million years and anytime you're
anywhere near there i'm scared
from my arse is clenched
um but anyway uh i do have a final
request today
okay so
uh cool let's do this one so hey boys
i've got a dilemma
maybe you can help out got this guy that
i fancy a lot
we dated for a very short time three
years ago and then kept in touch
and we've had encounters here and there
what bugs me about him
is that he isn't consistent i think i've
seen this one but continue for a few
weeks he'll be
all in talking texting and then become
aloof just out of nowhere
hasn't wished me ever hasn't wished me
ever for my birthday
president ever wished me he hasn't ever
wished me a happy birthday that's what
i'm saying in the
world every week we get on this hasn't
wished me
a happy birthday ever basically um and
kick and this keeps messing with my head
he's a great guy checks off all items on
the list
except consistency he doesn't always
want to meet up or always come over for
sex
so i'm thinking he isn't a [ __ ] boy or
am i just missing something
i have called him out on it a few times
and he's given me the
um i don't think i'm going to change
crap i mean i really like him
and i've fallen for his potential what
are your thoughts on this
is he interested and just clueless or is
he just trying to keep me around
there's a few really good pinpoints in
there that i want to go so
overall synopsis um dated a guy for a
few
a few years ago for a little while ever
since then you've been on and off in
touch
um he ticks off a lot of boxes uh
you guys [ __ ] around sometimes but he's
super inconsistent sometimes he'll be
messaging you know what's up other times
you won't hear from him for a few weeks
you've offered him sex and and like he
doesn't
try and come around for just sex or
anything like that so you think okay
he's actually a nice guy
um you've called him out on his his
[ __ ] parts but he says
literally this is me um
you see a lot potential in him and you
are interested in him but you don't know
if he's interested in you
are you being clueless are you missing
something is he actually interested in
you or is he not interested in your talk
but just wants to keep you
on a leash kind of thing so you don't go
elsewhere like what are our thoughts
damn um i feel like that's that's a good
question you know
because she's in a situation where it's
not obvious
whether he's being a prick or not um and
she's brought it up to him
and yeah and she's brought up to him as
well so she's not just asking us
for stupid advice she's actually
confronting about the situation
hmm i'll let you go first cool because i
feel like you've got an answer already
i'm still i'm still thinking cool so
i've got not necessarily an answer for
the whole thing because it is quite
difficult
but there's a few bits in there that
like pinpoint like
frustrations for me actually no maybe
one thing in there that's a frustration
for me
all right in that it's the the bit that
she said that she's fallen for his
potential
okay so
like she says he ticks off loads of
boxes she he's a good guy he's not a fat
boy
et cetera et cetera et cetera there's
all these bad points about that she
doesn't like about him that she's trying
to like address with him
um but his potential from the good
points she's fallen for his potential
and that i feel is a very
female thing to do which always ends
badly and is
such a frustration to hear fallen for
falling for people's potential falling
for people's potential
not taking them as they are yeah but
picking out the good points that you
like about them
and think if i can make him more like
this he'll be the perfect yeah
okay that makes sense that makes sense
you have to take him
for what he is yeah not try and change
because it sounds like from if you read
through the message it sounds like
she's nitpicking at the good bits
and thinking oh he does this it was so
good so this bit is so good
he does this which is bad let me
speak on these bad points let me address
these bad points because these need to
get ironed out
i feel like she's refusing to accept
that
oh you know what he's got these good
points
these bad points are he's [ __ ] with
my head he's making me feel this way
he's making me
she's ignoring the way the obvious like
pros versus cons she's like let me
accentuate these pros
these cons are an issue but if i can get
rid of them
then we're good rather than just like
this is him as a person
yeah this person as he is right now yeah
is this the kind of person that i want
to be dealing with yeah
and it's a simple yes or no and then the
whole thing is resolved
yeah if if he is how he is he's aloof
he falls off the map sometimes i won't
hear from him for weeks and then other
times he
is is great uh when he's great it's
great when he's when he's away his
[ __ ] i've called him up on it and he's
openly said to me
big man this is how i am yeah deal with
it and you're saying oh this is [ __ ]
you're literally saying oh he gave me
this is who i am
i don't see myself changing [ __ ] that's
what she said he gave me the
um i don't see myself changing
crap is what she said and it's like
maybe that isn't crap bro maybe you
should take that and be like
okay cool so this is you do i want to be
with someone who's just going to fall
off the map
yeah and i'm guessing the answer is no
so maybe the answer is no but a lot of
people
um i get that because i now that you've
said that i could completely agree with
what you said
because it makes total sense but also
it's hard to
i'm assuming obviously that's why she's
asking us because it's hard to see that
from a third person's perspective
obviously
yeah when you're in too deep and
emotionally
you can't think logically nine times out
of ten you can't think logically
and the fact that she's holding on to
the positives or the pros like you said
but wants to really try and change these
cons
then obviously you're not taking him for
who he is because i wouldn't if the
roles were reversed
basically if the roles were reversed how
would you feel how would you feel if
he was consistently hollering you blah
blah blah yes there are days that are
great but the days are [ __ ] he's trying
to pull you up and he should
say what what do you really want from me
kind of thing and he's like big man this
is who i am
i don't need this drama right now take
me or leave me yeah yeah yeah
if he said that if he was consistently
acting like that towards you how would
you feel you'd probably want to lock him
off because he doesn't get your
he doesn't doesn't know who you are
brother doesn't matter you're just a
very laid-back person
and you're not that interested like
you're he's clearly not basically
he's clearly not interested in pursuing
a serious relationship with you yeah
that's a
fact yeah that's a fact yeah but he
likes you
but he likes you out and he's clearly
not just sex because you've offered him
sex and he's like
no yeah he's like cool i'm just cool i'm
busy there or whatever you know what i'm
saying
he's not you clearly said he's he's not
a fuckboy yeah he maybe he just lives a
very casual lifestyle
yeah he is not necessarily assumed
you're a part of that casual lifestyle
but he's not going to change the way he
acts
as long as you're single and he's single
in his head he might be thinking well
why not
why wouldn't i message her yeah if he's
thinking about you maybe he's messaging
you when he's thinking about you and he
doesn't message you when you're not
thinking about you yeah
he's not interested in pursuing a
relationship with you he's not
interested in
um embellishing his good sides and
making you think he's something that
he's not he's happy with his flaws
he's happy with the situation as it is
clearly um he's happy with
how everything is because he's not he's
clearly not trying to change anything
it sounds like the only one that's
trying to change something is you and
he clearly has say that he doesn't want
to change so it's kind of it seems like
a point of just like
maybe stop confusing like you seem like
you're confusing yourself
because you can't understand him him
yeah but just you don't necessarily
need to understand him you just need to
accept him and that's
hard for a lot of people to a lot of
people can't accept who people are
people want to change
people think they can change other
people for their benefit
yeah or they might think that if i
change if i change you james as a person
it's gonna benefit you oh hundred
percent people think hundred percent a
lot of people think a lot of people
don't even
consider maybe you are very comfortable
as you are
and you love your life as you are yeah
i'm not trying to change me for [ __ ]
yeah yeah but people don't get
especially obviously opposite sex as
well especially if they're trying
hard to be together it's hard for people
to grasp and
maybe she might obviously now think that
he's just a waste man like he's not
trying to be serious with anyone
yeah this is just the time of his life
that he's in
a lot of people a lot of people may not
understand that there are certain stages
of life
that you have to go through before you
actually like
settle and be like not settled um settle
for someone less but just like settle
down in general
a lot of people don't like me personally
i feel like
doing this podcast has given me the
purpose in life i'm 30 years old based
i'm nearly 30 years old do you know what
i
mean
and it's taken me almost 30 years to
find my
passion and purpose and know what i want
to do
for god knows how long i mean prior to
that
i was happy i was happy but i
thought i was fulfilled but i wasn't
until i started doing this
so now that i know i've um now that i
know that this is
this is it for me like this is what i
want to do i know there's no
distractions anymore there's nothing can
stop me until
we've reached that goal of you know um
quitting our jobs blah blah blah making
this our full-time job
and then i can be like okay now that
this is patterned i can now start
looking for my my woman
yeah maybe he's not in that place where
he's mentally
um not necessarily mentally stable but
can actually
entertain anything else other than what
he wants to find right now because
people don't know where people are
unless they speak and a lot of people
don't want to also
tell people what they're up to because a
lot of me personally
obviously this is a public thing so a
lot of people know that i do this
podcast
but if it was something else for example
let's say i was trying to start up a
random business
i wouldn't want to be boasting about my
business that is on the come-up
to a lot of people until it's actually
there oh yeah because a lot of people
don't like to talk about their stuff
until
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah so yeah he
could be just in limbo right now yeah
and now a lot of people don't get that
yeah it was a real thing bro
being in limbo is a real thing yeah
until you're there you won't know
yeah exactly and like you're clearly
looking for something that he's not
looking for
and that's really sometimes it sucks
like sometimes you
actually have to look at things in black
and white yeah clearly you're looking
for something that he's not looking for
she's not accepting it and you're not
accepted that's literally yeah she's not
accepting it he's
you're looking for something that he's
not looking for and he's making it clear
that you're not looking for it but
because that doesn't really
sit not at one side it probably doesn't
sit well with you and another side you
probably can't understand it
because maybe you're the type of person
that doesn't just do talking stages
maybe you're the person that doesn't
just casually see someone maybe you're
the type of person that likes to pursue
[ __ ]
like if you're going to talk to someone
maybe the kind of person is like i'm not
going to waste my time talking to
someone unless i can see a future
so if you're that type of person it may
be difficult to understand that some
people
just enjoy casual relationships with not
necessarily
people but people are happy with just
like oh
i'm super casual with this person we
talk when we talk and we don't we don't
yeah and he might not see
at all from this perspective that you
see it from you're seeing it as like oh
he's trying to keep me on a string
like he's trying to keep me around he
talks to me just enough so i don't like
[ __ ] off in some way he might not be
thinking that
at all yeah like you might message him
the next day and say oh by the way i've
started seeing someone
i don't think we should talk anymore and
he'd be like cool that's fair enough
yeah it was fun while it lasted i'll see
you on the other side so yeah from the
sounds of it just sounds like you guys
are in two different spaces
yeah man you need to you need to um not
necessarily cut your losses but
you like you like james said you're in
two different places at the moment and
you can't forcefully change someone and
you can't
expect someone to change purely because
you think you're the right person for
them as well
so yeah yeah it's cool so sometimes just
one of them ones
if it ain't working out just and it's
tough to hear as well because i'm
assuming
you clearly like him because you
wouldn't be in a situation if you didn't
like him so
it's just one of them once you have to
cut your losses and move on really yeah
because he's he's
not in the place you are he's not in the
place you are and if you think if
you like listen to this and think uh
well no i'm actually looking for anyone
sometimes like if you actually just take
a perspective and think like
oh like if i if i thought about this
situation as
not my next relationship would i
be happy with the situation that we have
yeah you might actually think like i
actually don't
have an issue with it i just want to
understand what's going on maybe that
kind of person like
maybe once you understand and you think
okay so maybe this is just what it is
maybe we're just this casual uh people
that just message each other when we
want to message everyone and don't when
we don't see each other when we want to
and don't when we don't
and like if you actually think about
that way you might think i don't have i
actually don't have i've got nothing
else going on yeah
i don't have an issue with that they
might as well you might as well and then
you might enjoy it a lot more you might
stop
[ __ ] like going crazy in your head
thinking about what's going on
and just enjoy it for what it is a lot
the thing i think
a lot of what i would say a lot of women
but people might want it just for the
security purposes
because no one wants to be no one wants
to be alone like let's let's be honest
no one wants to be a leader yeah like
you said um
if you don't think about an aspect of
this being your next thing
yeah would you be happy but maybe a lot
of people obviously we don't know how
old this this lady is or whatever
but um she could be at a stage of her
life where
she can't afford to be [ __ ] about
anymore so yeah yeah again context matt
said we don't know
but i get your point obviously yeah cool
man it's just one of them ones
yeah yeah yeah all right bless well
hopefully that answers your dilemma
maybe hopefully hopefully um i have
a topic for you oh cool
do you remember the first time this
could have been
mine's mine's years and years and years
and years ago but do you remember the
first time
you ever got friend zoned yes
hit me i don't i remember the first time
i got friendzo but i don't remember
i don't remember that much specifics
because i can't remember how i felt
about it but i just know i got
friendzoned
okay so i was in year this was in
nigeria i was in eight
um i'm not gonna say her name because
she's quite popular um now anyway um
i fancied a girl who was older than me i
may have said this on here before i'm
not too sure
but i do remember talking about this and
i remember maybe to you but anyway
um there's a guy i fancied this was in
year eight i was in nigeria
and to me she was banging like she was
the one for me like she was the most
banging ticket
yeah then one's in it yeah lost it over
bank most banging thing in all year
and i think um it was a there was a
point where we were crossing paths
so i was going one where she was going
the other and i think i stopped her
obviously i think
we were talking anyway like she knew who
i was i knew she was wherever we would
talk to his friends and blah blah and i
think i must have told her
that i like her or i'm trying to do a
thing i can't remember the ins and outs
and she was like she stopped me then and
there she was like no i'll never date
anyone younger than me
bear in mind we're in the same yeah big
mommy get eight and so
are you what do you mean you're never
gonna date when i'm younger then where's
your mindset
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i was like
yeah cool
and i think i was so annoyed because i
think she was only a month older than me
oh wow either that she was either born a
month before me
or a year and a month before me it was
one of them was i can't remember the
night in 91 yeah so she was either born
in january or she was either born in
january 1990 or as opposed to january
night name so it was one of them ones
and i was like damn that's so harsh
but i could i don't know whether i could
kind of tell
she may have thought she liked me
but she was sticking to her guts about
not dating oh okay yeah yeah
but it was just then again like i said i
was year eight so i don't know whether
at the time it was a hard pill to
swallow
because i don't remember the feeling i
felt but i just remember that happening
and i remember her telling me oh the
reason is because i will never date
anyone younger than me
and i was like cool i can't argue with
that do you know what i mean
i would argue with her i'll say shut the
[ __ ] up we're in the same year what are
you even talking about i was like
and you've also dated zero people who
weren't rude
you've dated no one i was so angry
you've never been on a date
so i'm not accepting this as an excuse
tell me i'm ugly
i'm younger than me tell me the truth
i'm younger than you i'm older than you
so i was just how does she even know
that you are she was older than you
like i said obviously we spoke like so
cool you were cool it must have been a
situation where everyone knew yeah yeah
yeah yeah i could have been in year nine
i don't i just know i was in nigeria
yeah yeah yeah so oh fair play
it was i don't think i was embarrassed
because it was just us two yeah
yeah yeah yeah again i don't
i don't remember feeling anything
afterwards
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah because i
remember i had a girl that had a
girlfriend that yeah
yeah afterwards obviously oh fair play
um yeah oh fair play cool man you
remember what about yourself
um i think mine was year seven year
eight as well
mine was like it was like
how to explain it it wasn't that
traumatic
but it was like back then i didn't know
the work there was no term friend zone
as far as but i remember thinking if
there was a word for this
this is how i feel yeah because i
remember it was like um
so it was uh a ting
so i just i think it was year seven
right it must be yes yeah seven year
eight i kind of i basically moved to my
the school where i moved from luton to
north um
back end of year seven so i think this
must have been like early year eight
okay so um
there was a ting i say ting this is a
girl
right this thing
yes seven seven basically this guy i
thought this
goal was so buff yeah i wouldn't
necessarily have an issue saying her
name but like she's in my bedroom and
then like not even till now
and it's just like don't say anything
yeah i'm not gonna say it's just like
the same way i wasn't gonna say this
one's there yes i'm not gonna probably
never
listen to it but i probably know people
that know her that listen yeah yeah
i remember seeing this girl the first
day i started this new school yeah and
i'll be thinking this school's gonna be
all right
if this is what this is the caliber
we're talking about this school's gonna
be just fine it's gonna do just fine i'm
gonna swim in this glass
um but anyway i thought she was banging
forever yeah
and then she was doing she was dating
one guy
that i was friends with because one of
them things was
like you're basically friends with
everyone in year seven do you know what
i mean yeah yeah you're basically
friends with everyone so i say he was my
boy but
you're friends with everyone yeah i
think we used to walk home from school
together so i'm like we'll call
but me and this girl everyone know who
it is now but then this girl had
um the same what was it
we had the same birthday we have to we
have the same birthday okay so once we
establish that
um we would like for some reason we'll
talk more okay
and i remember one day the first ever
day she spoke to me here
i've never um first ever did she spoke
to me this is when you're young
you read into everything you read into
everything thinking she's gassed
um i was walking as lunchtime i was
walking
to meet my boys on the field and she
stopped me she's like james james james
james
i was thinking this [ __ ] knows my name
ah how does she even know my name i've
been here like two weeks
she's like change james i don't think ra
she knows my name all right sick bet
like one yeah
and then um i was thinking i i remember
thinking in my head like don't say her
name don't say that
pretend like you don't know who she is
but i was gonna say what's her name but
obviously i was just because you know
yeah yeah don't say anything pretend
like you don't know who she is i was
like oh
hi yeah what's up and she was like oh
have you got um
50p like i'm just a bit short for lunch
and i was like 50 yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah let it fan
i mean my what my velcro wallet like
50p yeah i think i had like a manual
wallet so i felt good
i remember this i remember this
i only had a two pound coin and that's
all i had for lunch
oh because the lunch was cheap back then
yeah and he had a two point and that's
all i had and i was like
nah i've only got two pound and i didn't
want to be
in my head i'm like i don't want this
this guy to think i'm broke
like say anyone's got a job yeah seven
you're like saying
anyone has any money i don't want to
think i'm broke so i don't want to be
like ah
i've got two pound you're gonna have to
run me 150 back yeah you know what i
mean
so i was like ah i've only got this two
pound coin
my goal was like that will do that's
fine and i was like
yeah if i'm gave her the thing i was
like
she must fancy me she asked for 50p
she's got two pounds she knows man's
name it's only been a couple weeks
yeah we've never spoke yeah she's
comfortable to be asking me for money
little i don't know she probably asked
everyone
to speak that day yeah yeah she would
have got three lunches galore yeah
banging she's already got it from
everybody use your two pound the next
day yeah
she's your two parts she just put it in
the pot oh and i think she must be down
yeah and then um i remember i think a
few weeks after that
we had a sports day and i was um
i loved sports though oh my god and this
guy was rapid as well
and then i remember i won my race and
then
as i'm walking as i'm stunting back to
my class you know you have to sit in
your line with your club
i'm just standing back to my classmate
you new man on the block just run past
all you man
it's minor like i'm i'm stunting in this
new school yeah
and then i seen her like guy like james
i saw you win and i was like gasped
sick and then she had her race next she
won her race and she come straight over
to me like did you see me win
i'm thinking this guy's on it this goes
so on it it's
it's uncomfortable bruh i'm looking
around does anyone even see
this this is this girl's banging and
she's
on it yeah it's mine up and then i'm
thinking i'm gas
now and then i remember she started
dating one guy
so i think this now we're moving into
like year eight now and the mean is
going in the same maths class
so we're talking talking talking she's
dating this one guy she comes in one day
aft
in maths and she's like james
he dumped me and i was like swear down
i'm thinking is he
fit is he stupid bro
he don't you like he must think he's
tier one
caliber yeah
i don't know what he's got yeah but i
don't all right but
he dumped you so she said i dumped me
and then she hit me with the the young
fear like is there something wrong with
me like
why is he like why did he dump me yeah
i'm drinking best i don't know
i hate got those answers and then she
was like oh like
she said something along the lines of
like why couldn't he be like like
someone like you like calling like you
and i was thinking this is it she's
gonna hit me up like you wanna go out
like she's gonna
she's gonna stick out on me after all
this time he's like i'm ready for it i
felt prepared
been ready because i'm actually sitting
behind us you know your arms on the back
of the chain you're thinking about
that i was ready for it i've done my
i've done my nose
yeah this is why we train i've read the
script you've read this i know it
and she was like and she said something
like
i'm just so lucky to have a friend like
you and she said like
twins and she hit me with like a spider
like twins
and i was like twins yay
i was thinking she thinks i'm one of our
girls she literally
sees me as one of her girls i i went
from
1 000 to zero
from i went from skyscraper to basement
in a second so she hit me with the twins
twins twins
fam as soon as my fist touched it i was
like wow
this whole time from day dot from the
two pound coin
she thought i was a female clearly
clearly
that's heartbreaking fam literally
heartbreak i'll see you guys she sees me
as one of her veterans
top brethren now i know i'm never going
to do it
i'm never going to do it you're never
going to do a thing with this girl
it was long fast she's banging now still
she's stay banging she's like uh um
she's not like how do i explain it she's
not like one of them things that you're
looking for
[ __ ] she's banging yeah she's just
like like a like a bass
fundamental naturally very good looking
person oh yeah you know what i mean yeah
yeah she's just about to stay consistent
for a while um but yeah that was the
first time i was like
wow damn that might be the only i think
that might actually be the only time
that's happened to me i can't think of
another time that's happened
um is there another time i've been
friend-zoned
off the cuff that i can't remember it
was cause as soon as you asked me that
one i just explained was the first one
that came to mind
because i was probably the first person
i've probably ever like asked out kind
of thing
or tried to ask out um
i'm trying to think throughout my years
i don't think so
i don't know i don't think so i think
that could be the only time i don't put
myself in positions like that
i wasn't the consequential thing but
yeah after that situation i i
you closed up i locked it down i locked
it down
ah mad it was long
i'm so happy that i kept my [ __ ]
mouth shut
i never told any of the brethren that i
thought she was on it
i'm so that would have changed happy the
whole game
can you imagine i i can't yeah i'll
still
be scarred from it till now i know if i
started running my mouth like yo this
girl
is on it that would have been torment
it would have been torment that would
have been torment
damn yeah it's tough stuff and stuff oh
that's annoying stuff stuff
stuff it's
it's so it's how do i put it
do you not think it's annoying that
women
women kind of necessarily control like
secondary school kind of thing in terms
of
how do i put it
in terms of like what you get out of it
so obviously my situation with that girl
in nigeria i asked her out boom
she's not she said i'm never going to
date anyone younger than you or younger
than her
and that kind of that was my first like
i didn't have a girlfriend before that
do you know what i mean but i moved on
after that
but that must have shaped me yeah you
know what i mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and i'm assuming this girl was like the
first
because you said it wasn't like yeah
seven no oh yeah it was like the first
thing
that that i tell you what in terms of
perfect example of shaping you it was
the it was the first thing
that i'd ever liked
like knowing for a fact that i liked
this person
before they'd even seen me so i fancied
this person
before they'd seen me because more time
before that if i ever found out girls
fancied me
like you're sick you're five years six
you're seven like before that
it would more be like i'd know about
them
i'd find out they fancied me and then
i'd convince myself that fancy them back
do you know what i mean
if i'm like i'll swear okay cool like oh
she advances me that's cool
[Laughter]
um so yeah yeah i remember yeah
that was the first time i'd seen someone
yeah i thought jesus christ is the
best-looking girl i've ever seen
and then obviously weeks months later
i'm thinking rah
she is definitely down yeah she's deaf
she definitely fancies me yeah and she
has no idea that i fancy her
and she definitely fancies me that's the
first time what i thought
wow this is actually like gonna pat that
this is actually gonna be a thing
only to find out that i was completely
wrong have you ever thought that
maybe because obviously you said you
didn't tell a soul right you kept it to
yourself
so there was obviously never gonna be
any murmurs that you like her
yeah yeah so do you ever think that
maybe there was a point or a time that
she did like you but because
you gave her no advances and obviously
you i'm assuming you gave her no
advances i would give nothing yeah you
gave her no advances and obviously it's
not like you told any of your boys and
any of your boys leaked it like
girl group chat and blah blah blah she
was just thinking okay maybe he doesn't
like me
because she clearly was attracted to you
in that like in some form or
something yeah yeah yeah yeah because
the conversation flowed you guys spoke
yeah
so did you ever feel like it's because
you never not necessarily shot your shot
but like dropped a hint that maybe that
is the reason why
that she didn't or maybe the reason why
the only thing i can get out of james is
being a bedroom because he clearly
doesn't bro maybe i've never really
thought about that deep
never thought about any female in my
entire life yeah yeah yeah i think
for me all that time in my head in my
head you always assume
back then or even till now you assume
girls especially you assume
they know they're as buff as they are i
know amy to the point where it must give
them
such confidence yeah because when
they're that buff yeah in your head
you're thinking you're so buff that if
you fancied me you would just tell me
yeah because you can't be scared of me
rejecting you
because you are bragging yeah because
there's no there's no way i'm rejecting
it i i can't i can't reject you i've got
no choice
i've got no choice but to go out of you
because you're unbelievable that's the
kind of mentality i had about her
okay is that that even though she didn't
act that way yeah i thought
you're clearly the buffett's going in
our year for
i remember probably in the year above as
well
from like between year seven and year
nine you're probably in the top three
office things so there's no way in hell
you if you fancied me that you wouldn't
tell me yeah or if you wanted to go at
me you wouldn't tell me yeah so
in my head though the way it shaped me
is that i feel that that gave me the
the mindset that like i'm not buff
enough
to secure things that i fancy yeah do
you know what i mean yeah the type of
girls that i'm attracted to
i'm not actually buff enough to secure
yeah and that actually i think i carried
that on oh yeah for the rest of my life
of course of course of course even till
now oh yeah right
like and then the times where it has
happened
i'm shocked flabbergasted i'm
flabbergasted every time like you can't
possibly like me
you're too banging and you chose me yeah
i know
standards are rock bottom you can do
better if you're choosing me your
standards are wrong bro
any time i've thought a girl is banging
yeah
for her to like move to me or what and
she moves to me or whatever i always
think
what are you thinking yeah you can do
much better than me
ah that's peak um did you ever
be the first time sorry that would
probably just wrap up that would
probably be the first time that happened
where i thought that i thought like cool
like now i know in terms of the
bluffiness scale yeah i know that's it
okay and that makes sense that makes
sense did you ever
meet or see the bread that dumped this
girl because you said oh he dumped me
this
this chick after he dumped her yeah do
you know not even after you done but did
you ever see them did you ever see this
guy
do you know who this guy was oh he was
my boy yeah yeah oh yeah i forgot you
said he was your boy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember
walking home with him that night
after school walking home with him
because we lived on the same street oh
man i remember walking with him and i
was like big my wife what are you
doing don't be asking him questions i
was grilling it are you all right he was
so nonchalant about it
oh so like he was just almost like
what's your problem
you know what i mean i've been thinking
why would you do that yeah i was like
what
why would you do that yeah what possib
what the [ __ ] do you have going on yeah
that means you're too busy for this yeah
you don't need her that you don't need
her and i can't remember what he said
but he was just i remember his demeanor
was just so much like bro get over it
like
why do you care like so what if i don't
say like it is what it isn't it i'm
thinking
he's different already you've got hoes
fam i don't know what's going on we're
in year seven
year seven bro i think actually no at
this time we'll probably like early year
eight
damn because i remember in year seven
the way it worked i don't know how i was
in your school but my school in year
seven
you're in the same class with everyone
obviously you got your form yeah and
then math
art science every everything is the same
class i can't remember that's the ascent
from
the way it works in my school you've got
your one set and that's your class for
[ __ ] everything
apart from form definitely i remember
yeah
they start separating you maths english
science yeah different classes yeah and
then every and then you've got your
normal class for like art history
geography
uh pe them kind of actually know p was
split as well no no p you know p
was the same set um so i remember that's
how it was
um and then in year eight because she
wasn't in my main like set for year
seven
okay and then yeah because i remember
when i found out i was in her class in
year eight for maps
i was like [ __ ] you know secured secured
so you definitely yeah they dumped her
damn man you know i was like ah you've
lost your mind because
man said what you do so what's your
business yeah right he's looking at me
like
are you nuts why the [ __ ] do you give a
[ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] hey robin's your
lust
oh my god that's jokes um but yeah do
you want to wrap it up
i've actually gone on my ideas are you
going either yeah
um i should need to find it
just do a quick one that already seems
longer
liner
right i don't think i've read this one
before but i screenshot it
hey guys i'm just going to get straight
to it i might be also for telling one of
my closest friends
how i don't i remember reading this one
now this is a good one
this is a good one all right hit me i'm
ready hi guys i'm just going to get
straight to it
am i the also for telling one of my
closest friends how i don't want to
listen to her talk about her man
in brackets who is also my ex because i
haven't fully healed from our breakup
we have been on and off since 2017.
they were together before we knew each
other broke up and now are talking again
when i told her when i told her to stop
she got taken aback and acted all weird
that night
i don't want her to come i don't want
her to feel like she can't come to me
anymore
what do i do so a quick recap
um her close friend and her ex are going
out they went out before
her and this man were together so they
went out
broke up then i'm assuming her and then
she went over there she went out with
now her friend is now speaking back to
the ex so i'm assuming that's the way
the order of the pattern went
um that's hideous
and then she's asking um she's asking
her not to talk to him anymore
and she was taken aback by it and how
basically what should you do because she
was
acting weird all night and i'll discuss
it on the board
i mean that
do you have anything off the cuff not
off the cuff brav no i feel like
that off the cuff first of all
i understand that you
you i feel like if you are friends with
some okay i'm going to use me
for because it's easy to explain if you
dated a chick
before i had met a chick like didn't
even know she existed you dated this
girl blah blah you broke up
i have now met this girl me and you what
boys
if i've met this girl i've probably
i'm probably going to tell you oh i'm
there's this chick i'm seeing
and if i've told you this chick and you
told me oh big man i used to date her
it's done it's locked it's done like so
long the fact that
you've let it the fact that you've dated
this guy broken up with this guy
and now your friend is now re-dating him
again and you feel some type of way
you have no place to feel some type of
way yeah it was her ex first from the
jump
it was her ex from day one and now
you're saying ah big man please
i'm still yeah you're saying i'm still
sore from done the break up i'm not
ready for the you to be challenged
oh you're oh you're sore what about me
i was sore you didn't give a [ __ ] you're
gonna give a single jumped on that dick
when i was sore
you're going to sit here and you're
going to hear about it
what's wrong with people yeah what kind
of advice did you expect me to give you
it's the honest question you should be
asking us yeah what kind of advice do
you expect because
from the sounds of it he she dated him
first
you dated him after and now she's dating
him again yeah from the sounds of it
unless we've got it completely
wrong it doesn't it doesn't sound like
it reads like she dated him first then
you date him and she's dating him again
that's what he reads like to me so
you'll be a bit of a hypocrite if you
say and i don't want to hear about it
you're a huge hypocrite because when you
were dating him you were
you were hungry dory you didn't care
about her feelings yeah
and now she's back in a picture with my
man it's like ah
you're dating my man or your day and my
ex i'm still hurting blah blah blah it's
like
well no not really because no you can't
he was like
you can't pick and choose when to be a
friend yeah
when it's okay to express how you feel
yeah i mean it's not that's not fair
that's not fair on your friend because
clearly
your friend even if your friend had an
issue with you dating this guy
she clearly didn't let it affect your
friendship or yes
yeah yeah clearly you're still boys do
you know what i mean yeah and she
she held her tongue yeah yeah for the
sake of the friendship yeah but you
can't do that
now the tables are turned you're a bit
bitter yeah yeah yeah you are the artist
you are the only other rapper
[Music]